in the beginning the most important
thing is just to shut up and put your
reps in
whenever i try to change anything
my number one rule is 100 days
or i don't even start having new goals
without new habits is kind of like
you know having a new car without wheels
wanna be happy
build a life not just a business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you
know there's something more inside you
too you've got michael jordan level
genius at
something so today let's live your best
believe life and learn how to develop
habits
that last enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one put in the reps with james clear
there's this professor at the university
of florida he's retired now
he was a photography professor his name
is jerry olisman
and at the beginning of the semester he
would have this film photography class
and he'd bring the class in and he would
split him into two groups
he said everybody on this side of the
room you're going to be graded on the
quantity
of work that you do this semester and
everybody on this side of the room
you're going to be graded on the quality
of work that you do this semester
and you've further explained it by
saying that
for your film photography you're going
to be responsible for having
100 pictures if you do 100 photos over
the course of the semester that'll be an
a
if you do 90 it'll be a b if you do 80
it'll be c and so on so it's quantity
for this group you only have to produce
one photo but it has to be the most
perfect photo that you can make
the best photo that you can make an
interesting and interesting thing
happened
at the end of the term all the best
grades came from the quantity group
not from the quality group and what
ended up happening was that while people
were busy experimenting making mistakes
learning how to you know play with
composition and so on they would come
across
a really great photo and while the
quality group was busy theorizing about
what perfection would look like
and how to take the perfect photo and
not actually honing their skills
they ended up only making something
mediocre or average and
the important insight here especially
for habits is that in the beginning
the most important thing is just to shut
up and put your reps in just make sure
that you
hone the skill right and you can start
to think of it the way that i like to
think of it is that any outcome that you
wish to achieve
is just a point along the spectrum of
repetitions
so if you have few reps to more reps and
you can imagine an easy goal
moderate goal a hard goal the more reps
that you put in the more that you
more likely you are to achieve that goal
so maybe point a
is you know let's take fitness squatting
100 pounds point b is squatting 200
point c is quoting 300.
maybe you need to put in 100 reps or a
thousand reps to get to point a maybe
it's 5 000 to get to point b maybe it
was ten thousand to get the point to see
rule number two make longer term
commitments with john assaraf
when we talk about how do we create
rituals or how do we change
habits um that last
the first thing is to have a different
expectation
than i'm going to change in a day or a
week or in 21 days
whenever i try to change anything
my number one rule is 100 days
or i don't even start so if i want to
let's say stop caffeine it's a 100-day
commitment
so first i make longer-term commitments
and then i design a plan to retrain my
brain
around the expectation of
following through i make pre-commitments
in advance so if i say let's say i'm
going to stop drinking coffee
yeah i say okay i'm going to stop
drinking coffee i commit to it for 100
days
and then i write out well what will you
do
in the morning when you wake up and you
want a coffee
what will you do when you're at a
restaurant with friends and everybody's
having a coffee what will you do so you
counter any of the behavior
when you know the trigger is going to
happen every habit has three parts to it
there's something that triggers the the
the emotion
there's the behavior and then there's
the neurological
biological reward so when you understand
the habit part of any ritual you
understand that
because we are conditioned a certain way
we're going to have a trigger whether
it's a flower whether it's
waking up whether it's a girl or a guy
or
or children coming home it triggers
a response in the brain or reaction in
the brain
well if we change the behavior over the
course of 100 days
we'll still get the reward and if we
pre-commit to what we're going to do
when we say
uh maybe today i'll have the coffee and
tomorrow i won't
maybe today i'll have the pizza or the
dessert and
i'll catch up tomorrow well if you
pre-commit in advance
that you're not going to take that
action then that's step one step
two is when you have the trigger if you
interrupt the behavior for one or two or
three or four minutes you
interrupt the neural pattern in the
brain also
so you come up with strategies is when i
feel like having a coffee or dessert or
the pizza or
the croissant okay then
here's what i'm going to do instead for
five minutes
and that way i can interrupt the pattern
if you do that
long enough you'll start to develop a
new
neural pattern you'll start to develop a
new behavior
and if you do it for at least you know
66 days but preferably 100 days
you'll start to develop a new way of
thinking
and being and doing that will overshadow
the other pattern in the brain very
interesting yeah so there's there's a
there's a psychology behind it but
there's also
the neurological processes of the brain
and what happens
is our brain doesn't like change yeah
so any time that there is change
the brain see it feels uncomfortable as
soon as it feels uncomfortable
it'll send signals to the motor cortex
of the brain it'll send
messages and we'll start to rationalize
we'll start to tell ourselves well i
shouldn't do it because of this well
maybe today's not a good day we'll i'll
start today you know but i won't
continue until
next week or you know what i really
don't want this we start to talk to
ourselves
and when we understand what the brain
does whenever we try to change
then we can start being in control of
the brain and we can
override the automatic responses there's
something
called automaticity and automaticity
states that anything that i repeat over
and over and over again over a period of
time
will go from conscious effort
deliberate conscious effort willpower or
persistence and it'll become
automatic so we just have to know how
long
that is and some things take a week some
things take
60 days some habits that people have for
20 30 40 50 years take 200 days
and so you start off with a 100-day
window and you ask yourself am i willing
to give a little bit of effort for 100
days
to remove this destructive either
thought pattern or
destructive behavioral pattern in order
for me to have something
greater and better than what i have
right now
so it's very important you you focus a
lot on what you will have
or what you who you will are who you
will be
in the future to keep your motivation
yeah if you think about this one of the
best
examples that i ever came up with is
imagine if i give you
a hollywood script right now okay
and i say to you if you
learn this script for the next six
months
i will give you 10 million dollars to
be on stage to deliver that we're gonna
film you
and if you're amazing you're gonna have
a chance to win an academy award
what will you do with the script
starting today
i start to learn start to learn you
start to read it you start to
emotionalize it you start to practice it
you start to
you start to do everything possible
to become something that's in writing
something that came out of somebody's
head that they wrote a script for that
you don't have any idea what it is
but if you made a commitment to becoming
that
person and you rehearsed it and
practiced it
every day you wouldn't get it right the
first day
or the first week for the first month or
the first month
but if you knew there was a big payday
emotionally
spiritually financially and that people
would go to the theaters and love to
watch it and they'd laugh or cry or be
sad and be happy
because you were able to take them on a
beautiful emotional rollercoaster ride
then you would become that role
yeah most people are interested
they're not committed and the difference
is when you're interested you do what's
convenient and what's easy
when you're committed you do whatever it
takes
so can you repeat it sure
when you're interested you do what's
easy and what's convenient for you
yeah but when you're committed i'm gonna
get that result
you put everything into it until you get
the result
rule number three set up triggers with
brendan burchard
i know you all have big goals big dreams
big aspirations just like i do
you've got ambitions to become an
amazing person to build your career
to create contribute to give to be an
awesome human being but
all of that is impossible without great
habits set up if you don't have routine
and structure set up in a way
that will keep you on track then you'll
fall off and and having new goals
without new habits is kind of like
you know having a new car without wheels
you know
the habits are the wheels they are the
things that make you
able to achieve the goals so you got to
have good habits
but the challenge for most people isn't
that knowledge i mean you know you need
to have good habits
it's you can't keep the habit going
right
have you ever started it the new year
you're going to get healthier and you
start that habit of working out more on
a more regular basis
and then it goes away or you say you
know i'm going to be more kind and more
patient and more awesome to my partner
my lover
and you start being nice for two or
three days and then on the fourth day
you're a jerk
you know and you're like what happened i
said i was gonna be nicer
it's that you didn't set up the most
important thing you needed to maintain
a habit you have to set up trigger
moments
to activate your habits what do i mean
by that
well let's say you want to become a
better person
you know you want to become more kind
more patient
more loving with people now you can just
set that intention or write that down in
your
vision in your your journal or set up on
a vision board that you look at once in
a while
but in day-to-day life it's not enough
you need things to trigger
you to remind you to be that particular
kind of person right it's almost like if
you could have a little angel speaking
in your ear all day long
to tell you what to do and how to be
you'd obviously become
better well that makes sense well let's
use that idea
let's use that idea by setting up alarms
on our phones that trigger us to do the
very things we need to do
this is gonna be so basic you're gonna
laugh and then also tell you how i
literally taught this to fortune 50 ceos
and they said it was the one thing that
changed their life
the most dramatically so let's start
with this let's have a goal in mind
let's say you want to become
more present and calm throughout the day
again you could write that down on a
journal i'm going to be more present and
calm
you could meditate in the morning saying
today i'm going to be more present
and calm and you could you could start
out with good intentions
but those fall apart without a trigger
moment set up throughout the day to
remind you that
so what if you did this what if you just
set up on your phone three alarms during
the day with a label
that said close your eyes
[Music]
take ten deep breaths in remind yourself
to be calm
so let's say you're going through your
day it's crazy right it's 10 a.m and
also
bing your phone goes off you look down
and it says close your eyes
take 10 deep breaths and then again it
happens at
2 o'clock and again it happens at 6 pm
and again it happens at 8 pm what's
going to happen
you always look at your phone don't you
it's going to go throughout the day
you're going to forget and the funniest
thing is i've had so many people do this
worldwide we're talking about hundreds
of thousands of people i've taught to do
this
hundreds of thousands and they tell me
all the time that changed everything
and you'll think once you set it up that
the next day you you'll you'll
forget about it no that alarm will go
off you forgot you set the dang alarm
there it goes off in your face you're
like all right i'm trying to be
calmer and more present close my eyes
take 10 deep breaths re-ground myself
here we go
you can't do it once a day you have to
have moments throughout the day that
trigger you to enact the new behavior
i know this makes sense to you but it's
a challenge for a lot of people because
they never set those things up
so what if you did it with an alarm so
for example
for me on the opposite spectrum i don't
want to just be calmer and more present
i want more
energy throughout the day so here's what
i do one of my big trigger moments is
every time my butt hits a chair i don't
care if i'm on a plane
or i was like where we're shooting here
i i wrote a lot of my books here i wrote
the motivation manifesto here
i wrote the charge here and if i'm going
to write
my butt hits the chair i grab my phone i
open the timer and i set
50 minutes now at 50 minutes the
timer goes it starts buzzing and i look
at that and i go oh that's my
trigger to get energy so i stand up i go
get some water
i take a glass of water drink it down i
do some stretches
and i do some exercise just really
briefly or i'll go for a walk whatever
it is but i'll do something
that usually takes just two to five
minutes then i'll sit back down
i'll set that 50 min alarm and i'll work
and what that does is every 50 minutes
it triggers me
to change how i'm physically moving it
changes my attention
so that throughout the day i'm
continually refreshed
so i never have that two three four
o'clock time where i'm like ah
you know why because i've triggered my
day so
that my energy is maintained throughout
the day makes sense right this could be
as simple as
let's say you want to be healthier in
your life okay
let's set up some trigger moments for
you in this way let's say
every time you drop off the kids on the
way back to the house
you stop at the grocery store and get
some fresh produce
that's just a trigger it's like okay did
one thing
drop kids off now tied to that triggered
from that action
drop kids off is go to health food store
or let's say you want to get healthier
in the morning one of the easiest ways
to help people maintain a better
exercise program is this
set a trigger you wake up in the morning
your first action is to drink water
put your exercise shoes on might get
dressed if you're naked just saying so
you get dressed put your shoes on
you go downstairs or you go to the gym
and
that's the trigger you woke up you do
these actions
nothing interrupts those actions that's
the action and you have to have those
set up
one of my other favorite trigger moments
to set up
is door frame triggers what do you mean
by that when you walk
into a new room to have a psychological
trigger go off in your mind
that you've associated with that door
frame so let me give you an example
if i walk into my house at night after
like if i've been working
all day and i'm gonna walk in i'm gonna
see my lady i have it so when i
ever walk through the doors of my house
three words repeat
off immediately in my mind because i've
done it so many times consciously
i went to the door i said the three
words said three words said the three
words
and i did this so many times that now
when i walk through a door
my mind automatically triggers those
three words
and i remember to be those three words
so what words would you love to have
describe you as a person that you would
be happy if that was
how people described you what would
those words be
have those and now set them up in your
life i teach executives do this as well
i have them have a door frame trigger
when they walk into their office in the
morning
as soon as they walk through that door
frame they have boom three words go
through their mind about how they want
to be perceived as a leader
i have them set up another dwarf every
time they walk into a meeting into the
conference room
when they walk through the doors of the
conference room they have another three
words that trigger off for them
and it just reminds them how to be
so these aren't big crazy things a lot
of people they think they have to
completely change their life
what would change your life completely
is setting
up more trigger moments and associations
that when you see something you do this
that when this action is taken
then that happens that when you
have the opportunity to set up alarms on
your phone you set them up
so that you're interrupted in your
everyday life
to remind yourself to stick to the
habits
to stick to the intention you do that
enough on a continual basis
you'll find yourself in so many ways
completely
rejuvenated and i promise you'll stick
to your habits
even more and once you do that you know
that everything
changes all right my friend evan
carmichael's book listen
humans are built to serve some people
are built to serve the world
others want to serve the 25 people
closest to them
but in either case humans are built to
serve so if you're not happy right now
it's because you're not serving enough
you got to pick up this book because
it's so inspiring to remind you that
we're all here to contribute
to make a difference to make an impact
and this is your field guide for that
rule number four release your toxic
beliefs with robin sharma
a lot of people listening may be
thinking jay i've been trying to work on
my health for a while
i've been trying to work on my mindset
you know i know i've got emotional stuff
to deal with and yeah i'm kind of
getting to that soul set right like like
you said like i'm not i'm not even sure
i'm there yet
habit formation you talk about the habit
formation protocol right you talk about
actually building habits and i
personally feel that
building and breaking habits should have
been the first thing we learned at
school
because it feel it feels like the thing
that affects our whole lives i look at
any change and it's always about habits
walk us through your
approach to building and breaking habits
absolutely and i totally agree with you
jay they teach us history and they teach
us arithmetic they teach us geography
and they teach us
you know whatever other language is in
school
why don't they teach us before interior
empires why don't they teach us
you said something very powerful why
don't they teach us how to work through
wounds you don't get invited to a
birthday party in fifth grade
there is a wound there you lose a love
when you're 16.
there is a wound there you start a
business when you're 22
there is trauma there and i think that
is in many ways the missing link in
leadership and personal mastery
and that's really you know i'm
passionate about the 5am club
because i get into that in in the book
and i worked four years on the book but
it's really 22 years of my
my learnings and teaching in the book
and that is a missing link because
everyone's talking about psychology and
people are talking about habits and i'll
answer your question of course
but what about dealing with trauma you
know carl jung said we all have this
shadow side i mean we all have this well
of repressed
pain and anyone who's listening who goes
well that's not me
it's subconscious so a lot unless you've
done the work you don't even know about
it
but it's that pain and self-loathing and
self-hatred
in the 5m club i say you know we have a
magic inside of us the saints call it
the light or
god or nature a luminosity
and what happens is when you do the work
to
release your toxic beliefs and move
through your pain and
how do you do it you just feel it and as
you feel through
all the toxicity and the hurt and the
wounding and the disappointment that's
called a human journey
what is left as you release it you
access your light you access your primal
genius
you access creativity you're productive
because you don't have all this
emotional baggage you're carrying
through the day
you've you know i believe
that the real artist the real key to
success is joy and inner peace like
that's why
a lot of the billionaires they have all
the things and they're not happy
you our nature is joy
peace bliss love
and when you release that trauma
it just shows up because that's who we
truly are
and rule number five the last one before
very special bonus clip
is use the 20-second rule with thomas
frank
there's this book called the happiness
advantage by a guy named sean aker
and it contains one of my favorite
principles about habit building
which is what he calls the 20-second
rule
so the whole idea is if you want to
build a good habit make sure it takes
less than 20 seconds to start doing it
so steve's example is great have the
violin right in the living room every
time you pass it it's just right there
you can pick it up and play it
i do the same thing with my guitar so i
went out and i bought a really nice
guitar recently but it's
it's nice and i live in a dry climate so
i have to keep it the case
all the time with a humidifier and that
makes it kind of a pain
to take out and play so i keep my cheap
guitar
so i can have it on the living room all
the time i end up playing that guitar
probably
75 of the time but that guitar ensures i
play every single day
just because it's out yep and that's why
i've gotten as good as i have
now i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're going to enjoy but before
that it's time for the question of the
day
i want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video and
your plan
of action for the next week when you
watch something and get motivated
and just get inspired you have a 35
chance of actually following through but
when you get motivated and then you
actually create an action plan for what
you're going to do you
increase it from 35 to 91 chance of you
actually following through
and when you share your plan publicly
that jumps to
95 chance of following through so i want
that for you
i want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video and your plan
of action for the next week
put it down in the comments below so i
can celebrate
you your environment has been perfectly
created to keep you exactly where you
are
everything around you your friends your
family the media you consume
all keeps you exactly where you are if
you want to raise your standards and
raise the quality of your life it starts
with raising your
environment so here's a story i haven't
told in a while when i was building up
my youtube channel and i closed my first
multi-year deal with the big brand it
was with a ceo high-powered ceo
one of the largest companies in the
world especially in the entrepreneur
space
and it was going to be me and him on my
channel every month
answering questions from you guys from
the audience we did a live stream every
month
and it wasn't me interviewing him or him
interviewing me it was both of us
talking about a certain topic and then
taking questions and i remember driving
with my dad
he was getting a new car and we had this
long drive out for whatever reason
the place we wanted to buy the car was
super far away and so it gave us
this chance to talk in a car and i just
told him about this new deal that i had
signed
i remember him asking me evan what gives
you
the confidence to feel like you're on
the same level as this guy
and he didn't mean it in a in a negative
way it was it was in a more awesome
way it's like man look at where you've
come from because my family is very
humble like you have to be very humble
you have to appreciate what you've got
and so how am i now how do i see myself
on the same stage as high-powered ceos
being his equal answering questions
and the question took me aback and i
thought you know what he's right i mean
if this was evan of five years prior i
would have felt
not worthy i would have felt like i
couldn't do it i would have felt like
this is too big an opportunity for me
like i couldn't be the guy to do it
so what changed five years ago to where
i was at that point
it was my content it was my channel was
all the videos that i'm
putting up because in my head it was a
big deal in that this is the largest
deal i had signed for
three years but more that i'm
around oprah every day and and dan pena
every day
in kanye west every day and all these
people every day
and so i feel like i'm with them
and and so this ceo deal wasn't that
huge a deal because i had changed my
environment
right i'd raise the stakes in my
environment and that raises your
standards
and so i realized man this is crazy how
important my channel is to myself at
least to my own growth if it's not to
you at least to my own growth
because you often can't see it on a
daily basis i could not pinpoint
the one video i uploaded or the one day
that i felt this is it it's happened
but if i look back over a five-year
period a one-year period a six-month
period even a three-month period think
about who you were three months ago
if you're investing in yourself by
watching these videos or reading books
or anything else if you're investing in
yourself
even just look three months back and
think have i grown
how much have you grown in the past
three months you may not see it on a
daily basis
but with months and then more months and
then more months and then years if you
keep on the path
you'll see some tremendous results may
not even recognize the person who you
used to be
and that's why it's so important you
raise your environment
[Music]
if you want to know the seven rich
people habits that you need to try
check out the video right there next to
me i think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe
and i'll see you there as a person as
busy as yourself when do you
do email it was very difficult for me to
figure out
where my boundaries were because
i'd grown up poor and didn't have
anything